[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos amigas prestad mucha atención a
estas sorprendentes declaraciones de la
primera ministra de Suecia la líder
socialdemócrata Magdalena Anderson la
primera ministra sueca dice que la
integración de inmigrantes ha fallado y
ha alimentado El crimen de bandas la
integración ha sido demasiado pobre al
mismo tiempo que hemos tenido una gran
inmigración la sociedad ha sido
demasiado débil los recursos para la
policía y los servicios sociales han
sido demasiado pobres se ha permitido
que la segregación llegue Tan lejos que
tenemos sociedades paralelas en Suecia
vivimos en el mismo país pero en
realidad es completamente diferentes
Magdalena Anderson primera ministra de
Suecia a ver que una líder
socialdemócrata que además está en el
poder haga declaraciones como esta sobre
la inmigración no es algo nada pero que
nada común algo muy serio tiene que
estar pasando en Suecia no os parece A
qué se refiere exactamente la primera
ministra Por qué el tema de la
inmigración ha pasado a estar en el
candelero en uno de los países más
abiertos del mundo que es exactamente lo
que pasando en Suecia Pues bien veamoslo
Por cierto antes de seguir un apunte te
has preguntado alguna vez Cómo ganan
dinero y Cuánto ganan los grandes
gigantes tecnológicos como Apple
Microsoft alphabet o Amazon y ojo que no
es una pregunta menor hablamos de
empresas cuyo valor combinados superar
los 7,5 billones de dólares más de 5
veces el pib de un país como España
hablamos de empresas que han sustituido
a los grandes grupos industriales y
petroleros como las empresas más grandes
del mundo Así que la pregunta es cómo lo
han conseguido amigos amigas creo que la
respuesta puede sorprenderos Así que si
queréis saber más no os perdáis el
último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido el
canal de información financiera
demostrativos con el que participamos o
dejo el enlace en la descripción dicho
esto continuemos
cifras de pánico
[Música]
prestad mucha atención a la siguiente
cifras porque estoy seguro que a más de
uno os van a sorprender y mucho en 2021
se registraron en Suecia 335 tiroteos
que se saltaron con 47 personas
fallecidas sí vale si nos estás viendo
desde Estados Unidos o desde América
Latina estos numerosos pueden parecer
casi una broma Casi casi un arcadia
feliz si tenemos en cuenta la diferencia
de población el dato es infinitamente
mejor que el que cada año registra
Estados Unidos o prácticamente cualquier
país latinoamericano por ejemplo en 2020
tan solo en los Estados Unidos los
homicidios y tiroteos le costaron la
vida más de 23.000 personas hablamos de
escenarios completamente diferentes sin
embargo amigos amigas para los cánones
europeos los datos de Suecia sí que son
llamativos
Suecia es el país de toda Europa donde
más están creciendo los crímenes
relacionados con armas de fuego y tiene
una de las tasas de fallecidos más altas
por ejemplo mientras que Suecia tiene
una media de cuatro muertes por millón
de habitantes al año por armas de fuego
la media europea se sitúa en 1,6 además
a diferencia del resto de Europa la
tendencia en Suecia es creciente
un dato curioso todo esto supone por
ejemplo que la probabilidad de que un
hombre de entre 15 y 29 años Recibe un
disparo es 10 veces más alta en Suecia
que en Alemania Suecia a la cabeza en
tiroteos mortales en Europa según
informe en menos de una década Suecia ha
superado a Italia y a los países de
Europa del este en tener el mayor número
de tiroteos mortales en Europa Pero esto
no es todo en 2019 por ejemplo se
registraron 260 delitos con explosivos
en toda Suecia un incremento del 60%
respecto al año anterior hablamos bombas
y artefactos explosivos que suelen
explotar en espacios públicos sobre todo
en los exteriores de urbanizaciones de
apartamentos y en pequeños negocios
sorprendidos Pues si a todo esto le
sumamos también que este país tiene las
tasas de violaciones y violencia sexual
más altas de toda Europa y que además
los delitos de odio contra minorías Como
por ejemplo las personas lgtb también
están al alza Entonces tenemos el combo
casi perfecto Es evidente que en Suecia
Hay un problema
[Música]
Eso sí sorprendentemente si nos fijamos
en todos los delitos la tasa de
criminalidad de Suecia no es
particularmente elevada está en la media
europea es decir que el país nórdico
tiene sobre todo un problema con las
armas los explosivos la violencia sexual
y los ataques a minorías o dicho de otra
forma en el contexto europeo Suecia
tiene fundamentalmente un problema con
los crímenes violentos y de corte sexual
y esto Esto es lo que explica que los
suecos sean precisamente y por mucha
diferencia los europeos que más
preocupados están con el crimen para
ellos es ya la primera preocupación y
esto también es lo que explica las
palabras de la primera ministra
Magdalena Anderson que vimos al comienzo
de este vídeo fijaos
ahora bien llegados a este punto la
pregunta que Seguro seguro muchos os
estáis haciendo es que demonios está
pasando en Suecia qué diablos explica
esta semejante ola de violencia Pues
bien la mayoría de los tiroteos y las
explosiones en este país tienen que ver
con bandas del crimen organizado
en el país nórdico 8 de cada 10 tiroteos
tienen que ver con bandas criminales el
problema que más inquietud está causando
es que más de la mitad el 53% de los
sentenciados a prisión nacieron en el
extranjero un porcentaje que si tenemos
en cuenta tanto las personas nacidas en
el extranjero como las que pertenecen a
una segunda generación se eleva hasta
casi el 90% de los sospechosos de
protagonizar tiroteos
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas lógicamente con
este vídeo no pretendemos señalar a
nadie por su origen todo lo contrario
sabéis que en visualpolitik nos gustan
cosas como la libertad de circulación y
que pensamos que los movimientos
migratorios son un poderoso motor de
prosperidad siempre y cuando las cosas
pues se hagan bien claro está por eso
con este vídeo queremos poner sobre la
mesa algunos de los factores que pueden
dificultar una integración efectiva y
que son lo que explican que la situación
en Suecia pueda ser radicalmente
distinta a la de países como Australia
Nueva Zelanda o incluso los Estados
Unidos recordáis El que veíamos al
principio del vídeo la primera ministra
sueca dice que la integración de
inmigrantes ha fallado ya ha alimentado
El crimen de bandas pues Exactamente eso
así que para entender toda esta
situación tenemos que hacernos unas
cuantas preguntas de verdad el aumento
de los crímenes violentos en Suecia es
solo culpa de los inmigrantes qué
responsabilidad tiene aquí el poder
público es decir los políticos en que ha
fallado si es que lo ha hecho el sistema
de Suecia Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
única culpable
amigos amigas en Suecia la delincuencia
relacionada con la inmigración tiene un
componente clave a la hora de unir ambos
fenómenos la exclusión social Pero un
momento antes de que alguno de vosotros
ponga el grito en el cielo no en este
vídeo no os vamos a contar la típica
historia de que la delincuencia está
justificada exclusivamente por la
pobreza y que por tanto las soluciones
dar muchas más ayudas y subsidios de
todo tipo Este es un tema muy complejo
en el que vamos a poder encontrar muchas
causas y en el que desde luego la
pobreza juega un papel muy pero que muy
importante pero amigos amigas Si algo
sobre en Suecia son precisamente las
ayudas y los subsidios públicos y de
hecho aunque pueda resultar
contradictorio este exceso de fondos
públicos puede haber contribuido a
explicar buena parte de este tsunami de
exclusión y crimen que ha experimentado
el país escandinavo al menos bajo los
carnes europeos y ojo Esto no es algo
que digamos nosotros y esto es algo que
hasta la primera ministra
socialdemócrata parece empezar a tener
muy pero que muy claro
[Música]
en Suecia la población inmigrante recibe
enormes cantidades de ayudas públicas
especialmente si son solicitantes de
asilo pero si hay un subsidio que
destaca por encima del resto es la
asignación por hijo un subsidio que no
es exclusivo para los inmigrantes en
1982 cuando Suecia comenzó a
experimentar tasas muy bajas de
natalidad se creó un subsidio que ofrece
suculentos ingresos a las familias por
tener hijos
[Música]
y no no hablamos de un cheque bebé al
uso Hablamos de una subvención que toda
persona residente legal en Suecia cobra
desde el mes siguiente del nacimiento
Hasta que el niño cumple los 16 años de
edad e incluso bajo ciertas
circunstancias esta ayuda se puede
extender hasta los 20 años y que ofrece
el estado sueco por cada hijo Pues
básicamente una subvención de 1.250
coronas al mes unos 120 euros o 126
dólares y sabéis que la población
inmigrante tiene de medida muchos más
hijos Así que este subsidio les favorece
particularmente Pero además de este hay
muchos otros que también los favorecen
especialmente
hablamos por ejemplo de las ayudas a los
alquileres para familias numerosas o las
ventajas en el acceso a la vivienda
pública o los subsidios directos en el
caso de los solicitantes de asilo entre
muchos otros programas Pero la pregunta
que muchos seguros estáis haciendo en
este preciso momento es a ver Enrique
que tiene todo esto de malo qué tiene
que ver con el problema que estamos
abordando en este vídeo pues ni más ni
menos que todas estas ayudas tienen
consecuencias directas sobre el mercado
laboral digamos que muchas personas
terminan haciendo de las ayudas algo más
que un recurso transitorio y ojo insisto
no lo decimos nosotros lo dicen por
ejemplo los datos de empleo Y además lo
dicen claramente
la peor parte se la llevan las mujeres
ya que muchos de estos subsidios es
incentivan su incorporación al mercado
laboral y su integración social que ya
de por sí puede resultar complicada en
algunas culturas por ejemplo según
eurostat en Suecia la tasa de empleo de
las mujeres nacidas en el extranjero es
casi 20 puntos inferior a la tasa de las
mujeres que han nacido en el país por
otro lado estas ayudas fomentan también
una falsa estabilidad económica que hace
que muchos beneficiarios no busquen
trabajos regulares precisamente Para no
perder estos subsidios esto es gasolina
para crear redes informales que terminan
favoreciendo la creación y el desarrollo
de grupos criminales y Bandas
[Música]
en Estados Unidos y Nueva Zelanda los
inmigrantes tienen tasas de empleo más
altas que la población nacida en el país
en el caso de Australia y Canadá la
diferencia es de apenas 3,4 y 1,7 puntos
respectivamente Pues bien en Suecia la
diferencia es de casi 15 puntos es decir
hablamos situación completamente
distinta Y eso eso no es todo
al reducir las tasas de empleo y
disuadir a muchos inmigrantes de Buscar
empleos formales a tiempo completo
también se reduce su grado de
integración y se merma su contacto con
el resto de la sociedad Y si a ello le
sumamos las políticas de vivienda
pública el resultado es un cóctel
perfecto para la gestación de netos un
ambiente particularmente propicio para
el desarrollo de las bandas de esta
forma se calcula que tan solo en
estocolmo hay unas 60 bandas de crimen
organizado operando a lo largo y ancho
de toda la ciudad La pregunta es tiene
todo esto solución Qué consecuencias
pueden tener estas políticas exactamente
qué es lo que quiere hacer ahora la
socialdemócrata Suecia pues amigos
amigas Como tantas veces ocurren las
malas políticas no solo conllevan malos
resultados y no casines también
conllevan malas respuestas O al menos
respuestas insuficientes
del blanco al negro sin rumbo claro
de repente Suecia está cambiando y lo
está haciendo A pasos acelerados incluso
Aunque el gobierno siga en manos de
políticos hacia el demócratas lo está
haciendo en la buena dirección Bueno ese
ya es otro debate el caso es que si
hasta hace poco Suecia era un ejemplo de
puertas abiertas ahora la reacción
social y política puede terminar
alimentando movimientos antagónicos y
hostiles hacia esa realidad Por ejemplo
si en el año 2015 Suecia se convirtió
con diferencia y ni el país que más
refugiado sirios acogió en relación a su
población ahora apenas 7 años después
los titulares que podéis encontrar en
Google si buscáis inmigración y Suecia
son muy pero que muy diferentes incluso
Suecia no quiere más inmigrantes ahora
el propio gobierno socialdemócrata va a
poner en marcha una nueva ley de
inmigración supuestamente para atajar la
causa de todos los problemas la nueva
ley de inmigración sueca endurece la
residencia permanente para refugiados y
visitantes con esta nueva ley las
personas llegadas del extranjero ya no
lo tendrán tan fácil para llegar o para
recibir las ayudas públicas tampoco Será
posible conseguir un permiso de trabajo
sin tener un contrato y además se
requerirá un mínimo de tres años
viviendo para conseguir la residencia
permanente y también se pedirá una
justificación de ingresos mínimos
mensuales de 810 euros la ley en sí
mismo no dice nada diferente a la de
otros muchos países europeos pero la
cuestión es que en este caso el objetivo
último es que lleguen muchos menos
inmigrantes por supuesto ese no es el
problema Suecia tiene muchos menos
inmigrantes que países como australiano
Nueva Zelanda o Canadá pero da igual
esta es la respuesta que quiere dar el
gobierno se hace el demócrata de
Magdalena Anderson lo que supone un giro
de 180 grados en la política del país
eso sí lo que de momento no cambiará es
el abultado
régimen de ayudas y subvenciones y
tampoco las políticas de vivienda para
evitar la formación de gatos más bien
todo lo contrario el gobierno
socialdemócrata de Magdalena Anderson
quiere poner aún más dinero sobre la
mesa sin prestar atención a cuestiones
tan relevantes como el nivel de empleo o
emprendimiento que tiene la población
llegada del extranjero dos factores que
junto a la educación resultan claves
para promover la integración
no nos equivoquemos el problema no es el
número de inmigrantes que hay en Suecia
el problema está sobre todo en el
ineficiente inadecuado régimen de ayudas
y subsidios de todo tipo al final con
este tipo de cambios se corre el riesgo
de criminalizar A toda la población
extranjera sin conseguir realmente nada
Y qué queréis que os diga que la
respuesta del gobierno sea reconocer el
problema culpar a la inmigración a hacer
cambios legales para que lleguen menos
extranjeros al país y querer regar luego
con más dinero los que ya están pues no
parece algo muy Sensato por muchos votos
que las subvenciones puedan darle al
gobierno porque amigos amigas el
problema de Suecia ni son los
inmigrantes ni tampoco la falta de gasto
social de hecho en este país el gasto
social medido en términos de pib es por
ejemplo un 52% Más alto que en Australia
Lo cierto es que todo apunta que el
problema es exactamente el contrario
pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti
con todo lo que has visto crees que el
verdadero problema de Suecia es la
inmigración o por el contrario es más
bien el resultado de unas malas
políticas públicas déjanos por aquí
abajo tus comentarios y ya sabéis si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
visualpolitik para estar al tanto de
todas nuestras novedades una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]